An important point. Even though we can predict the price of
a diamond based on a function for c's. One thing you
should not conclude with this exercise is that where you buy
your diamond is irrelevant. You almost surely pay more for the same
diamond at Tiffany's compared to Costco. Regardless you can use a
model like this to get a sense of whether you were
overpaying. One last thing, data and models are never infallible and
you can still get taken even equipped with this kind of analysis.
There's no substitute for establishing a personal connection and
lasting business relationship with a jeweler you can trust.